>>David Lieber: Alright, good afternoon Google
Chicago!
For those of you who don't know me, my name
is David Lieber. I am with the State and Local
Public Policy Team. For those of you that
may have seen me before I'm like, I guess
I'm like the new best friend that you never
wanted. [chuckles]
Today's event is a continuation of our Fireside
chat series which was inaugurated during the
2008 campaign season and continued in 2010.
The Chicago Mayoral Fireside Chat Series really
represents the first time that we've brought
the event outside of Mountain View and to
one of our other offices and I think we can
probably all agree that there's no better
place to do that in Chicago.
Our guest today is Mayoral Candidate Miguel
del Valle who came to Chicago at the age of
four and has lived here ever since. At a young
age, Mr. del Valle was tapped to run both
the Barreto Boys and Girls Club and the Association
House here in Chicago.
His political career began in 1982 when he
worked on the historic campaign of Mayor Harold
Washington. In 2006, he became the first Latino
elected to the Illinois State Senate where
he served for almost 20 years, rising to become
the Assistant Majority Leader.
In 2006, Mr. del Valle was appointed to be
City Clerk by Mayor Daley and in the next
year, 2007, he won a citywide election for
the same office. During his tenure, transparencies
have been a hallmark in the City Clerk's Office.
City Hall meetings are now streamed and archived
and ordinances and city budgets have been
made available through the City Clerk's Website.
So please everyone let's give a warm welcome
to our guest today, Miguel del Valle.
[applause]
[unintelligible]
[pause]
>>David Lieber: Thanks. So we're now a week
out from election and everyone is still trying
to obviously make their final decisions about
who they are going to support. And one of
the challenges I'm sure everyone has, particularly
those who are undecided, is how to distinguish
one candidate from another.
So the question for you is what distinguishes
you from other candidates and why are you
the right choice for mayor?
>>Miguel del Valle: Well it is a challenge
for people to distinguish because we still
have a system that because of funding puts
some candidates at a disadvantage. And that's
why I continue to advocate for campaign finance
reform because we can't have a strong democracy
if only millionaires and people with access
to large campaign contributions are the only
ones who can run for office.
That is not good for our democracy and so
we need to continue to look at how it is that
we level the playing field so that choices
could be made based on an individual's skills,
abilities, experience, track record, and not
based on who can afford to put more 30 second
spots on television that many times say very
little about who the candidate really is.
>>David Lieber: Um.
>>Miguel del Valle: So having said that, I
am, as you indicated in the introduction,
an individual who's lived in the City of Chicago
since I was four years old. I have had both
feet firmly planted in the neighborhoods of
the City of Chicago, I have worked in various
capacities doing community organizing and
as a community activist delivering human services,
and then entered the political arena when
Harold Washington was elected mayor.
I chaired one of his commissions as a volunteer
and then was motivated and inspired by his
historic election in the City of Chicago,
and then decided to leave a position as executive
director of a human services agency, Association
House, an institution established by Jane
Adams in the late 1800's in the City of Chicago,
as one of many settlement houses that were
established at the time to help different
immigrant groups settle in the City of Chicago.
So I left that position as executive director
and decided to run for office for the first
time without any prior political experience
and no political organization and no funding
and we were able to win an election where
I challenged an eight year incumbent in the
state senate who was at that time the Chairman
of the Senate Transportation Committee and
an individual very much connected with the
local political machine.
So I served in the Illinois Senate for 20
years. During the 20 years in the Illinois
Senate, I was a member of the Senate Appropriations
Committee and dealt with budgets four, five,
six times the size of the city budget, both
on the operating side as well as on the capital
side. So I have plenty of experience dealing
with fiscal matters, and then of course sponsored
lots of major pieces of legislation during
that period.
And then went on to become City Clerk where
then I've been an administrator more than
anything else even though the City Clerk's
office is one of three citywide elected positions
in the City of Chicago -- you have Mayor,
City Clerk, and City Treasurer. It is more
of an administrative function -- we're basically
the keepers of the record, of the legislative
branch of city government and we're the point
of access for the public to that record.
And one of the things I did when I came in
[chuckles] was develop and establish an electronic
document management system. Would you believe
that in the City of Chicago, a world class
city, things were done by paper,
>>David Lieber: [chuckles]
>>Miguel del Valle: journals etcetera produced
by paper. And so we've modernized the office,
we've used technology to bring the council
closer to the people putting the city council
meetings online, doing live webcasts of those
city council meetings, and we've done those
types of things.
So back to your question of what makes me
different: my experience, my knowledge of
neighborhoods in the City of Chicago, my long
track record of advocacy. I see things through
a different pair of eyes. I'm not the guy
who made $18 million in two years, but I'm
the guy who's been in the neighborhood fighting
battles year after year after year.
And now I've decided that I want to use the
authority of the Mayor's Office to tackle
the very same issues that I've dealt with
over the years: education, the quality of
public education in the neighborhoods; public
safety; access to affordable housing. Those
are some of the issues that I want to tackle
and I think that while I have a lot of experience,
I also have the heart for the neighborhoods
of the City of Chicago.
And I'd like to say that we've set a tone
in this campaign. From the very beginning
I said, "This race needs to be about the issues
in the neighborhoods. It needs to be about
the need for balanced growth and balanced
development in the City of Chicago. It needs
to be about engaging communities. It needs
to be about organizing communities" because
I'm a big believer in lifting communities
by empowering them to organize themselves.
I think the city can play a role in that so
everything we do whether it's the police department
and how it operates in the communities and
taking a CAPS program -- which is the Community
Alternative Policing Program -- and converting
that into a program that really operates as
intended which is to develop a relationship,
a working relationship, with individuals and
community organizations and churches and other
civic institutions, small businesses within
the community to take on issues of public
safety.
Those are the kinds changes that I want to
see and so I think because of my extensive
experience in working with neighborhoods I'm
in a better position to do that so that we
can really earn the title of "World Class
City".
Some people gave us that title a long time
ago --
>>David Lieber: Um-hum.
>>Miguel del Valle: but that title was based
more on what you see downtown. And what I'm
saying is that for us to really, really earn
that title we need world class neighborhoods
and that's my goal.
>>David Lieber: So I wanted to build on that
because you talked about sort of being a candidate
that's been involved with community activism
in the neighborhoods. Your campaign slogan
is, "A major for all Chicago, for every neighborhood."
Does that suggest that in a del Valle administration
that aldermen would have more authority than
they do now in terms of economic development
in matters concerning the ward or less?
>>Migue del Valle: They should have more authority
on just about everything. What I wanna see
aldermen is move away from dealing with routine
matters though the legislative process. And
by the way, we're going to get there and let
me explain.
Right now, in the City of Chicago, if you
own a small business you're starting a small
storefront operation, a bakery. I talked to
a couple the other day who have started a
bakery in Beverley and you want your sign.
[chuckles] You wanna put up a sign. You wanna
put up an awning with your name on it. It'll
take you two months.
And in order to do that you have to go to
your alderman and your alderman has to file
an ordinance and that ordinance has to be
approved, and so it takes about two months
because the city council meets once a month.
That's an archaic process.
Number one it shouldn't have to go through
the legislative system and so why not do it
administratively. You could still have the
aldermen sign off because the aldermen want
to control what happens in their ward and
certainly on zoning matters and other kinds
of matters -- that's what they elected for.
They're responsible for how the street looks
and what goes where.
So they need a role, but you can do that administratively
and then you can take that out of the legislative
process and use the legislative process to
deal with substance; to deal with legislation
rather than ordinances to put a stop sign
here or to put residential parking zones here
or there. All these things end up going through
the council and it shouldn't be like that.
Now we should have the council become a deliberative
body. If it was truly a deliberative body,
as it should be, then I don't think we would
have had the fiasco that we had with the meter
lease in the City of Chicago. That was put
together by the Mayor's Office. It was a plan.
It was negotiated behind closed doors, put
together and then presented to the City Council
for a vote within a two day period; a 75 year
lease where the city has given away its authority
to do a whole bunch of things including the
authority to determine how many meters we're
going to have in the City of Chicago.
If I wanna establish more bike lanes, for
example, or bus lanes because I wanna reduce
the flow of traffic downtown because I want
us to become a greener city and we're concerned
about air quality and a whole bunch of other
things, and I want to encourage the use of
public transit. If I want to do all that,
then we cannot do the, make the changes that
are necessary without compensating Morgan
Stanley, the company that has this long term
lease.
>>David Lieber: Um-um.
>>Miguel del Valle: If we want to, for example,
ease up on our harsh treatment of motorists
in the City of Chicago who, after getting
two tickets, parking tickets, within a year,
are booted if they don't pay those tickets
on time. And there are people who lose their
jobs and let's face it they aren't sometimes
able to pay within that period.
Well if I want to go back to where we used
to be, where we used to boot cars after four
or five tickets, then that triggers what they
call a compensation event in the contract,
which means that somehow, if we're easing
on enforcement, then that has an impact on
their revenue and therefore we have to find
a way and calculate what they need to be compensated
for. This is the type of agreement that was
entered into. Aldermen, many aldermen, did
not read that full agreement because they
didn't have the time.
And so if we have a more deliberative body
that takes time to conduct public hearings
and to give an opportunity for proponents
and opponents to chime in, which is what is
supposed to happen, then you're gonna get
a different kind of result. That is not to
say that we still wouldn't have leased the
meters because in this climate, in this economy
--
>>David Lieber: [clears throat]
>>Miguel del Valle: there's been tremendous
pressures on cities to come up with ways to
generate revenues and privatization has been,
of course, one of those ways.
So the pressure's still there. But how we
make decisions I think is definitely going
to change and has to change because, as I've
said, as mayor I'm going to liberate the aldermen
in the City of Chicago. And I'm going to allow
them to do their work because that's what
they get elected to do. They're there to represent
their constituents in their wards and they're
gonna have to make book in Chicago the history
has been strong mayor, weak council. I wanna
strong mayor, strong council, and I actually
want them to have to cast votes and assume
responsibility for some of the tough decisions
that are ahead of us regarding budget cuts
and as well as revenue decisions. Where's
the money going to come from?
>>David Lieber: Um-hum.
So you mentioned privatization and that's
obviously been a controversial subject whether
it be with the parking meter fiasco or now
with the festivals and the talk of privatizing
those and even the Taste of Chicago. Do you
think there is a role for privatization in
the context of good governance?
>>Migue del Valle: Well of course there is.
But before you take the step, lots of questions
have to be answered. Are we talking about
efficiencies? Are we talking about reduced
costs? Are we talking about taking a function
delivered or a service delivered by a group
of individuals who are city employees --
>>David Lieber: Um-hum.
>>Miguel del Valle: and then privatizing the
delivery of those services and then having
a company that is going to pay substandard
wages and then help expand the number of individuals
out there who are the working poor in the
City of Chicago?
>>David Lieber: Um-hum.
>>Miguel del Valle: Those things have to be
weighed, but there are some areas, for example,
I'll throw one out: recycling. Right now we
have 16 wards in the City of Chicago that
recycle. It's been very, very difficult for
the recycling services to be expanded yet
we need to go. If we're gonna be a greener
city, we're going to have to go to citywide
recycling. I wanna go to citywide recycling.
There's a possibility there of a private-public
partnership to do that.
Now we're gonna make sure if there's an agreement
there, that over the years we're able to capture
the growing value of the recyclable materials.
So all of that needs to be figured out and
we need to make sure that we don't enter into
an agreement that short changes the residents
of the City of Chicago.
>>David Lieber: So we have a tool here called
Google Moderator and in advance of this series,
we solicited questions from Chicago employees,
things that they wanted to hear and the number
one topic that was brought up and voted upon
and voted up was education. And so I'm hoping
you can talk to us a little bit more about
what your plans are for education and, specifically,
how do you plan on insuring that every student
in Chicago receives the same opportunity regardless
of what school district they live in?
>>Miguel del Valle: Well it's a very good
question. As you know, Chicago is the largest
school district in the state. Illinois has
about 869 school districts. We have more school
[chuckles] districts than just about any other
state. Chicago is the largest with over 400,000
students.
There are inequities within the overall public
education system in the State of Illinois.
We have a little over two million students
in public schools in the state in those 869
school districts. And of course we have a
financing structure that relies heavily on
local property taxes, too heavily. And we've
argued for a long time that we need to reform
how we finance public education in the State
of Illinois and shift away from the reliance
on local property taxes and more on the state
income tax.
Well, years ago I advocated for that and when
I was advocating for that shifting, I said,
"We ought to do it now because the day's going
to come, given the state's track record, when
we're going to end up seeing an increase in
the income tax and it's not gonna go for education
and we're not gonna be able to do that shift
because the money's going to be needed to
deal with the state debt."
Well, guess what's happened? That's what happened
this year. There was an increase in the state
income tax of two percent for four years and
then it'll drop back down to 3.75 percent.
We have a set rate in Illinois as you know.
But we haven't financed or reformed how we
finance public education. In the meantime
we have to take care of business here in District
299 which is the Chicago Public Schools.
And during my campaign, I've talked about
how in Chicago, with good intentions, we've
developed a two track parallel system of public
education with magnet schools, selective enrollment,
and charter schools on one track and the neighborhoods
on another track. And while I continue to
support academic options for kids and for
families, we have to focus in on our neighborhood
schools because that is where [chuckles] we
have some serious, serious problems.
>>David Lieber: Um-hum.
>>Miguel del Valle: I want a family, a young
family with a child who reaches preschool
age, who is ready to send their child to school
to not have to grapple with, "Do I [chuckles]
put my child in the school across the street
or down the block from where I live in or
do I find a school across town, a private
school or another public school that's selective,
with selective enrollment?" Today's there
an article in the Tribune today about the
gifted and classical programs and the number
of families that do all kinds of things [chuckles]
to prepare their little ones to take that
test because people are worried.
That's one of the biggest decisions that you
make as a family. Where are you going to send
your child to school? It's an important decision.
And so I want neighborhood schools to become
an option for families. Right now people are
looking all over.
Do you know that for high school, for high
school slots, last year there were about 13,000
applications for 3,000 slots? So that means
the 10,000 who didn't get in to a selective
enrollment high school in Chicago ended up
in the regular school or going to a private
school. And so that is the challenge.
Now some have said, "Well the only way you're
gonna get away from that and the only way
you're gonna really deal with this is by continuing
to create charter schools." We're not going
to charter school our way out of this. We
have to tackle the needs and the issues at
our neighborhood schools. And that's how you
build communities. We cannot build and stabilize
neighborhoods if all the kids [chuckles] in
the families are constantly leaving the neighborhood
and running away from the neighborhood. How
do you stabilize communities?
I see neighborhood schools as anchors for
the development, for stimulating all kinds
of activities. That's why I wanna see a community
learning center at every neighborhood underperforming
school. And by that I mean a center where
families can participate in educational and
cultural and recreational activities from
two in the afternoon 'til eight thirty, nine
o'clock in the evening and on Saturdays.
And we're doing this already. This is not
something that I'm just coming up with right
now. I did this as a legislator. I have schools
in my old legislative district where parents
are taking English as a second language classes,
GED classes, college credit courses, the kids
are there at the same time getting homework
and tutoring assistance, engaged in enrichment
activities which are important in these neighborhood
schools. Because in every neighborhood school
you find bright children who aren't being
challenged and they get bored and they, they
get bored -- one of the reasons for the dropout
rate. I've worked with kids who dropped out
of high school, dropped out of regular high
schools, and end up in alternative schools
and excelling and doing very, very well because
they were bright kids who were just not being
challenged and were just not in the right
setting.
And so besides the community learning centers
that we want to do that include the cultural
enrichment activities, then we want to establish
a program to reenroll dropouts. Fifty percent
of African-American high school students in
the City of Chicago drop out of school. About
43 to 45 percent of Latinos drop out of school.
We are not gonna stabilize communities, we're
not gonna build neighborhoods if we don't
pull them back in. And some of them drop out
because of concerns for public safety, gang
activity, other kinds of activities; they're
bored, they're not being challenged. There
are all kinds of reasons. They begin to miss
school, they fall behind, they fail courses
in the first year, and then they're out.
I increased the compulsory attendance age
in the State of Illinois from 16 to 17 because
I want schools to hang on to these kids longer.
And by the way, the compulsory attendance
age had not changed in the State of Illinois
since the early 1900s.
>>David Lieber: Hum.
>>Miguel del Valle: That's how long it had
been. When the compulsory attendance age was
last changed, the Cubs had won the World Series.
>>David Lieber: [laughs]
[laughter]
>>Miguel del Valle: Just to put it into proper
context here.
And so those kinds of changes are taking place.
Also dual credit, dual college enrollment,
working with our community colleges is something
that I wanna see more of. So kids could take
college level courses while in their junior
year and senior year in high school and then
that would facilitate the transition to our
community colleges or to four year colleges.
We don't do enough of that.
We have to change a lot of things. We have
to allow for school later on in the day. We
have to be more flexible with the scheduling
-- a long list of things that need to be
done. But it is my top priority. It's the
reason, I should say it's the main reason
why I decided to run for mayor and that is
to deal with the quality of public education
in our neighborhoods.
>>David Lieber: Hum. So Google has been on
somewhat of a hiring spree lately and we have
approximately 400 employees in this Chicago
office. There have been some concerns raised
with the legislature's increase in the personal
income taxes and corporate income taxes that
it's going to be difficult to attract and
retain talent and attract and retain the next
technology start up or technology company
whether that be Groupon or Google.
How do you plan to ensure that Chicago continues
to remain competitive as a global business
hub and is able to attract and retain the
best sort of talent here to build the city
and to build the work force around the city?
>>Miguel del Valle: First of all, I think
we will continue to be very competitive. We
have some of the best universities in the
country right here -- University of Chicago,
Northwestern. We have a great public university,
University of Illinois. And so we're gonna
remain very competitive.
The question is how do we create more opportunities
for more people in the City of Chicago so
that we're not a Tale of Two Cities, extreme
poverty in the surrounding areas. And I say
that [chuckles] when I take 290 coming in
sometimes and I see that beautiful skyline
in front me, to the east of me I see the Emerald
City. I always think of the Wizard of Oz ?
>>David Lieber: [chuckles]
>>Miguel del Valle: and what it took to get
to the Emerald City. Sometimes I feel that
that's what a lot of people do. How do you
get to that and how do you expand those borders
so that everyone is part of that Emerald City?
And I think that certainly dealing with the
quality of public education is an important
piece of that. I've talked to small manufacturers
who want to develop advanced manufacturing
here in parts of the city on the west side,
and the first thing they tell me is that they're
concerned about being able to find the skilled
work force.
And so that's why programs like the one, the
Austin Polytech Program on the west side where
they're working with a couple of manufacturers
and training the kids, machinists to deal
with today's equipment. More of that needs
to be done.
On the tax policy side, folks, I know it's
painful. I've yet to talk to a business person
who says, "Yeah, go ahead increase my taxes."
I don't know of anyone who does that, who
says that. I'm sure they're out there.
But the fact of the matter is that Illinois
was about to start defaulting. Providers have
waited nine months, eight months to be paid.
The only state worse than us was California,
in the country. There was really no other
alternative but to raise that tax. I'm glad
it was done temporarily and not permanent
even though it's the legislature so they could
always go back in three or four years and
then make the tax increase permanent. I would
hope that that doesn't happen. But the fact
of the matter is that we need to pay our bills
and I really think that this threat that's
out there, the Governor of Indiana and New
Jersey putting up a welcome sign --
>>David Lieber: Right.
>>Miguel del Valle: and trying to lure companies
away from Illinois is just not something that
I think is gonna play out. Sure, some people
will make a decision based on that obligation.
But I think Chicago is strong and I think
many parts of the state are strong and businesses
will do well here.
>>David Lieber: Let's talk about something
that's maybe not nearly as sexy, tax increment
financing. You've talked a little bit on the
campaign trail about TIF surpluses which I
think surprised a lot of Chicagoans to hear
the term "surplus" and "Chicago" in the same
sentence. But can you talk a little bit more
about the TIF surplus and what if anything
you might do with any TIF surplus funds?
>>Miguel del Valle: Well first of all we don't
know what the amount is and we're the ones,
we being the city, will determine what the
surplus is. But that determination gets made
by looking at what's obligated and what projects
are in the pipeline and once you subtract
all of that, then you see what's there, 'cause
TIF's generate about $500 million a year.
And this year for this current fiscal year
we used about $30 million or so for the budget
to deal with this year's budget. That triggered
the release of dollars because it's a formula
driven process to CPS of about $90 million.
I anticipate that we're going to have to do
the same thing for fiscal year 2012, because
we are at this point talking about a $650
million deficit and my guess is that it's
going to be higher than that. And so we're
going to have to use those dollars.
Now I also believe that TIF's should be created
for what was originally intended and that
is to spur economic activity in blighted areas.
We haven't done that. A lot of TIF dollars
have gone into the downtown area and so the
Mercantile Exchange got something like $15
million and Boeing and others have gotten
money.
I wanna see TIF's used to stimulate economic
activity in areas that need it number one,
and I want to see it tied to job creation.
And so if the job creation doesn't take place
then those TIF dollars oughta come back to
the city. So we're gonna do a lot of work
with TIF's. But I believe that tax increment
financing is a good economic development tool.
I'm not one of those who wants to do away
with TIF's.
>>David Lieber: Um-hum. And do you support
the Sweet Home Chicago proposal?
>>Miguel del Valle: Yes.
>>David Lieber: Okay.
>>Miguel del Valle: I supported --
>>David Lieber: The answer.
>>Miguel del Valle: the Sweet Home Chicago
proposal because we've had the CHA plan for
transformation. It's slowed down because of
the slowdown in economy, and I don't think
we're getting as many federal dollars as we
should be getting for the development of affordable
housing and public housing.
And so there's a desperate need out there
and we all know what's happening with the
housing market. We have a serious, serious
problems with foreclosures in the City of
Chicago and with some of the lending institutions
-- the banks walking away from some of these
properties and failing to secure these properties.
And so that is at the top of the list for
the next mayor and that is dealing with the
housing crisis --
>>David Lieber: Um-hum.
>>Miguel del Valle: that we have. Because
I think the market has begun to bottom out
and I think we're gonna see a turn around.
Property values are gonna start to go back
up and so we have to stimulate more activity.
There's a group in Brownsville that has a
wonderful project. And for those of you who
are familiar with Brownsville, it has a fabulous
history in the Africa-American community.
And I met with them a couple weeks ago and
they said, "Listen," they showed me, "these
are all the vacant lots that the city owns."
The city owns a ton of vacant lots and what
they want to do is take those lots and they're
working with a developer and they're gonna
build market rate housing as defined by the
community, in working with the developer.
And that kind of community driven neighborhood
development is what I want to see more of
in the City of Chicago.
>>David Lieber: Um-hum. We do wanna take some
questions from the audience. So if you do
have some questions feel free to line up at
the mic and ask anything that's on your mind.
But I do wanna do a quick lightening round
--
>>Miguel del Valle: Right.
>>David Lieber: which I hope will be fun for
you.
Question here: ketchup on a Chicago hot dog
unacceptable or impeachable offense.?
>>Miguel del Valle: I don't use it, I don't
use ketchup.
>>David Lieber: No ketchup. Alright, that's
good. I mean that was ?
>>Miguel del Valle: No.
>>David Lieber: that's a deal breaker for
a lot of people who are going to the polls.
>>Miguel del Valle: And no one should ever
admit that in Chicago.
[both laugh]
>>David Leiber: Favorite restaurant in the
city?
>>Miguel del Valle: Well I have a little Puerto
Rican restaurant Café Central on Chicago
Avenue which is probably the oldest Puerto
Rican restaurant in the City of Chicago, like
45, 50 years old or something like that.
>>David Lieber: Okay. Favorite search engine?
>>Miguel del Valle: Oh --
[laughter]
I thought there was only one.
>>David Lieber: [laughs] Say no more.
>>Miguel del Valle: I use Gmail and I forgot
Gmail is Google.
>>David Lieber: That's right.
>>Miguel del Valle: You guys have cornered
it. I tell ya.
>>David Lieber: [laughs] Blackberry, iPhone,
or --
>>Miguel del Valle: iPhone.
>>David Lieber: iPhone okay.
>>Miguel del Valle: I love the iPhone. Love/hate
relationship with the iPhone.
>>David Lieber: [laughs]
>>Miguel del Valle: You know those dropped
calls are frustrating.
>>David Lieber: [laughs]
>>Miguel del Valle: But I love the iPhone.
>>David Lieber: Cubs or White Sox?
>>Miguel del Valle: I'm a sports fan.
>>David Lieber: [laughs]
[laughter]
>>Miguel del Valle: But people laugh when
I say that, but I really am! I mean I'll sit
there and I'll go back and forth, I'm a surfer,
and I'll watch a Cub game and a Sox game at
the same time while I'm watching a Bulls game.
That's how I am. Love Cubs, Sox, Bears, Blackhawks,
of course.
>>David Lieber: Absolutely.
What do you think about another Olympic bid?
>>Miguel del Valle: I don't see it at this
time.
>>David Lieber: Yeah.
And here's sort of a curve ball here, but
other than your own campaign videos what's
the last YouTube video you watched?
>>Miguel del Valle: You know --
>>David Lieber: Is that too much of a curve
ball there?
>>Miguel del Valle: No well I have the YouTube
on my iPhone --
>>David Lieber: Yeah.
>>Miguel del Valle: so I've seen some videos.
>>David Lieber: [laughs]
>>Miguel del Valle: But I remember one with
a baby.
[laughter]
>>David Lieber: Yeah, there's lot of cats,
we have lots of cats.
>>Miguel del Valle: You have lots of cat ones
--
>>David Lieber: Yeah.
>>Miguel del Valle: and babies and every now
and then when I show my kids the dog video
--
>>David Lieber: Right.
>>Miguel del Valle: and all the kinds of different
--
>>David Lieber: I do.
>>Miguel del Valle: I just love seeing my
grandson. He loves seeing some of those videos.
>>David Lieber: Yeah, I do the same thing
with my three year old. It provides minutes
–of -
>>Miguel del Valle: Yeah.
>>David Lieber: entertainment.
>>Miguel del Valle: sure.
[laughter]
But by the way you guys you could see a few
good videos that have been put on YouTube
related to my campaign.
>>David Lieber: Yes.
>>Miguel del Valle: Like the bike guys. And
just a quick story. Some high school students
at Sullivan High School decided to do a video
criticizing one of my opponents on education
issues. And they put this thing up and I didn't
know, I didn't know these kids, they did this
on their own working with their teachers.
That YouTube video has now gotten almost 10,000
hits. So it's amazing and of course we love
it.
[laughter]
>>David Lieber: Let's take a couple of questions
here.
>>female #1: Hi, welcome Mr. del Valle.
>>Miguel del Valle: Thank you.
>>female #1: My name is Frances Young. And
in my family I have quite a few Chicago police
officers --
>>Miguel del Valle: Yes.
>>female #1: or family members that work with
the Chicago Police Department. I haven't heard
a lot from your campaign on what your plans
are. This has been quite a year for the Chicago
Police Department. We've heard like from all
of the mayoral candidates that, yes you would
replace the current superintendent and lots
of people have said that we will bring in
more police officers.
But right now the morale at the Chicago Police
Department is really low. What are your plans
to one bring up the morale of the Chicago
Police Department, what all over is your crime
plan for Chicago?
>>Miguel del Valle: And I've talked quite
a bit about that, but I don't have the millions
of dollars to put the commercials on TV.
>>female #1: Um-hum.
>>Miguel del Valle: So people like you will
say, "Hey he doesn't have a plan." Well that's
because I don't have those commercials.
>>female #1: [laughs]
>>Miguel del Valle: And those commercials
don't tell ya much anyway as I said. But I've
talked about the need to fill vacancies, but
I'm not going to pander to the Chicago Police
Department by proposing, for example, that
there be a discussion on residency.
>>female #1: Um-hum.
>>Miguel del Valle: Chicago police officers
should live in the City of Chicago and it
should be a requirement and should continue
to be a requirement. A couple of my opponents
have said, "Yeah, it's something we can talk
about." What are we -- we're tryin' to build
up the middle class in every neighborhood
in the City of Chicago. We're gonna allow
people to move out but earn their salary from
property tax payers and residents in the City
of Chicago who pay taxes? So that's wrong.
Community policing. One of my problems with
Jody Weis is that he really hasn't strengthened
the CAPS Program. So I wanna reinvent the
CAPS Program and develop a true community
policing model that's effective. And I understand
that there were budget cuts this year that
pulled police officers away from community
policing. That has to be reversed. We have
to move folks from administrative positions
and free those positions up for the front
line. That has to happen.
I've talked to Jody Weis about making better
use of the cameras, the blue light cameras.
When was the last time we saw a report on
TV that showed that as a result of video captured
of a crime being perpetrated, that that led
to an arrest and then to a conviction?
The cameras are not being used. People have
lost in the neighborhoods that desperately
need these cameras to function and trusted
the cameras initially, they've lost faith
in 'em. I dealt with a particular street where
there was a camera where on three different
instances, there were shootings practically
in front of the camera that should have been
captured, and each time I checked, either
the camera was not working properly, it was
not turned on, or it wasn't facing the right
direction because it scans. And so I was and
have been dissatisfied with some of Jody Weis'
responses.
On the other hand, it is true that crime rates
have dropped. It is true that the number of
incidents regarding police misconduct have
dropped, and so there are some positive things
that have happened.
But as mayor I would prefer to have my own
team. I doesn't mean that there isn't a role
for Jody Weis somewhere in the city, even
though he has a very, very huge salary. So
I know we can't find another place that's
gonna pay him as much as he's makin' now.
But I prefer to have my own team. I'm gonna
be held accountable as mayor, I want my own
superintendent in the Chicago Public Schools,
who by the way is an educator. And for the
police department I feel that we should be
able to find someone within the ranks who
can assume that position. And I think that
will do a lot for morale.
When Jody Weis came into town as an FBI man,
a good guy ?
>>female #1: Um-hum.
>>Miguel del Valle: when he put on that uniform,
that was a mistake. To this day a lot of police
officers resent that because he didn't, he
wasn't trained in the police department. He
wasn't a police officer, and so he was a civilian,
FBI person, and he came in and he still puts
on the uniform. That's, that may seem small
to us but to police officers, it's a big deal.
>>female #1: Yeah.
>>Miguel del Valle: And those kinds of things,
those kinds of missteps I think have led to
the climate that you have today, but there
are a lot of good things that Jody Weis has
done and we have to give him credit for the
good things he's done.
>>female #1: Thank you.
>>David Lieber: We'll take one more question
and then Mr. del Valle has to be on his way.
>>male #1: Hi, so thanks so much for coming.
Just jumping back to you were talking about
the City Council being a rubber stamp and
so forth. I'm lucky I live in the 32nd ward
so I have one of the few aldermen who voted
against the parking meter deal.
>>Miguel del Valle: Scott Waguespack.
>>male #1: Right, yeah. And my question is
I think you're being a little too generous
to say they were tied up with the minutia
of doing their aldermanic duties instead of
just kind of being in the pocket of daily.
I'm kind of wondering how much of talking
about setting the City Council free is related
to their positions not being so intertwined
with the patronage machine and how much of
it is the fact they're just the wrong people.
So if you were elected, how do you think that
would start to change?
>>Miguel del Valle: Well --
>>male #1: If you have the vast majority of
the same people in place?
>>Miguel del Valle: Well I'm glad you asked
that question because we may get as many as
15 maybe more new aldermen in this election.
So a new mayor and a huge turnover in the
City Council presents an opportunity for us
to really change the climate, change the environment,
change how the City Council conducts its business.
So that guys like, aldermen like Waguespack,
he's a very principled, very independent alderman.
I wanna see more aldermen like Scott in the
city council. As a matter of fact he's being
aggressively challenged right now because
of his independence and because he speaks
his mind. We need more aldermen like that
in the City Council.
That's again one of the things that distinguishes
me from the other candidates. I'm not gonna
get into details right now, but it's no secret
out there that one of the leading candidates
is helping funnel money to a group that is
working to elect certain aldermen, where they're
making big contributions to make sure that
certain aldermen get elected and, of course,
then the understanding will be that they will
then be beholden. That's exactly what we want
to get away from in the City of Chicago which
is what you're talking about.
And yes does that mean that we're gonna have
some difficult days depending on issues? Yes,
but that's democracy; you call that democracy.
And that's what people want in the City of
Chicago. I think there's been a whole new
generation. The demographics have changed
in the City of Chicago. There are a lot of
folks out there who want to see city government
tackle tough issues and to be, use a deliberative
process that's going to allow for public input
and for debate. And so I'm looking forward
to that and I will encourage that. And I think
that because of this turnover that's going
to happen, unlike in the past.
[pause]
>>David Lieber: Great.
Well, Mr. del Valle, thank you so much for
coming. We wanted to present you, we've been
here at Google Chicago for 10 years now, and
this is a 10 year, 10 stars anniversary --
>>Miguel del Valle: Ten stars, okay.
>>David Lieber: sort of a T-shirt. So thank
you so much ?
>>Miguel del Valle: Thank you.
>>David Lieber: for coming today. We really
appreciate it. Thank you.
[applause]
Thanks a lot. This is for you.
>>Miguel del Valle: Thank you folks.
>>David Lieber: Go ahead.